quand je serai grand je veux être la première
personne à se téléporter même si tu
pouvais le construire je l'ai déjà construit
c'est à côté de ta voiture volante
ça ne marche plus
Reid tu es fou
Merci
c'est notre devoir en tant qu'humain  êtres
à avancer dans l'inconnu mais
parfois
vous cherchez à découvrir une chose
et vous trouvez autre chose
je veux juste réparer mes amis nous ne pouvons pas
changer le passé
mais nous pouvons changer l'avenir j'ai besoin d'un
atelier résistant à la chaleur et d'un  véranda à gros cul,
ils sont dangereux et puissants,
ce qui les rend extrêmement précieux pour
le gouvernement, vous m'avez promis de
ne pas utiliser mes enfants comme armes,
vous me voyez arc rouge et vous ne
savez rien de ce qui arrive
c'est une chance de faire une différence
ou une famille si nous le faisons nous le faisons à notre manière et
si nous disons non dites
oui c'est la fin de votre monde et le
début du mien
que n'importe lequel d'entre nous il n'est pas plus fort que
nous tous
vous